[Music]
this was fun wait we having that sex
again yeah I'm just not that kind of
girl I only have sex once on the first
date I'm just gonna fall over
[Music]
it traveled be ready soon as he puts on
his pants
watch your learn by Oh crush have you
tell you something like I've been dating
this girl she's white a white girl hey
God look like you and your white girl
okay
we hate eros no that could be I'm
guessing it's a young single Pakistani
woman
this is zubeida for your files your
x-files that's your favorite show huh
the truth is out there
are you judging Pakistan is next top
model you know how we have arranged
marriage in my culture I'm so stupid
can you imagine a world in which we end
up together I don't know
I'm looking for Emily Gardner she was
checked in tonight there's an infection
we put her in a medically induced coma
coma you should call her family thank
you come on we're gonna handle things
from here I think I'm just gonna wait
anyway broke up I'm not sure why you're
here
I'm just gonna stay for a second it's
this seat
[Music]
is that lady still looking at me so 911
I've always wanted to have a
conversation with people you've never
talked to people about 911
do anything on koala games now I didn't
play you can't rhyme it you try to find
it word and nobody can run okay and then
down hinge yeah see you would win yeah
I think I screwed up with your daughter
yeah
[Music]
let me give you some advice come out
love isn't easy that's why they call
about
I don't have to get down I thought I
could just start saying something
something small we come out
Oh
[Music]
so king
[Music]